[Musik]
satte 4 Kilo so viel wiegen die Brüste
von Sex influencerin Jesse Bunny hier
sehen sie hinter mir aber man muss sagen
noch wiegen sie so viel denn das ist ihr
nicht genug sie will ihren Busen nochmal
vergrößern lassen von XXL zu
XXXL nur eine Person redet ihr ins
Gewissen Oma Elfriede
haben jetzt 2017 das sind also zwei
Kilogramm pro Seite und ich habe die
größten in ganz Österreich diesen Titel
werde ich sehr vermissen ich habe kein
Ziel mit der Körbchengröße zu richtig
aber mein Endziel ist auf jeden Fall
Holz doppelter von jetzt also ich habe
da keine kein Verständnis dafür für die
Jessy wenn Sie die Oberweite noch mal
größer machen
ich finde es nicht gut für die Jessy
ich schaut für mich nicht mehr
ästhetisch aus
[Musik]
mit größeren Brüsten und Spanien
deutlich größerer Polen Spanien Jesse
Bunny sagt tschüss zu ihrer Wahlheimat
Wien dann geht es mit Partnerin Vienna
in die echte Heimat und zwar nach
Nürnberg beide Frauen stammen aus Bayern
haben ihre Kindheit im konservativsten
Bundesland Deutschlands verbracht sie
wollen sich von ihren Familien
verabschieden vors endgültig nach
Mallorca geht jetzt geht es zu viennas
Oma Elfriede die Rentnerin wohnt in
einer idyllischen Gegend mit
Einfamilienhäusern wo noch jeder jeden
kennt
was gibt’s gut
Abend ja ich freue mich
muss doch sein die Party bevor sie auf
meine Lieblingsinsel gehen oh extra auf
Mallorca für dich genau so besuchen
kommst ja genau das ist schön
[Musik]
aufs umziehen ja wow auf euer neue
Wohnung auf Mallorca Mallorca als ich
habe da keine kein Verständnis dafür für
die Jessy wenn Sie die Oberweite noch
mal größer machen lässt also sie ist
sowieso sehr auffällig in die Medien ist
es zwar gut aber ich finde es nicht gut
für die Jessy einmal ist es
gesundheitlich mit ihrem Rücken und dann
ich schaue für mich nicht mehr
ästhetisch aus ja aber das ist natürlich
klar dass die Leute hinschauen Männer
haben zwei Brüste also Moment auswandern
habe ich jetzt keine Bedenken aber dass
das halt so weitergeht auf Mallorca mit
mit ihren
[Musik]
ja genau mit sozialen Medien dass das
halt einfach so weitergeht dass es geht
verdienen weitergeht
man weiß es ja
Ballermann sind notfalls geht um
Ballermann das ist doch ein Witz ich
kann bestimmt gut Stimmung machen
ich kriege das Trinkgeld
ohne Ende mit dem kannst du nicht
überleben mit dem Trinkgeld das wird uns
ein
ich sag testen
ich habe das gerade mal probiert klappt
aber nicht die explosive Doku über Jessy
Bunny läuft übrigens heute Abend um
23:25 Uhr hier bei Bild TV direkt nach
unserem Sextalk komm doch mit Julia
Siegel ja bleiben wir aber noch ein
bisschen bei XXL vorbei Bau von Jessy
Bunny Oma Elfriede das haben wir gerade
in den Beitrag gehört hat eine ganz
klare Meinung das ist zu viel aber was
denken sie ist dieser Busen Wunder oder
sonderbar
[Musik]
nur sagen was sie von diesem Brüsten
halten einfach künstlich und plastisch
nicht schön also mir gefällt es nicht ja
nicht mehr gesund nicht gesund und vor
allen Dingen also überhaupt nicht mehr
schön das jetzt die Bunny was halten Sie
von der Optik
wie schläft sie denn was sagst du dazu
zu groß bisschen
hässlich das sieht nicht so ästhetisch
aus das sieht einfach gemacht aus es ist
so wie Plastik die werden jetzt aber
noch größer noch größer er ist aber
nicht gut
so
sah die Dame vorher aus
[Musik]
hättest du nicht machen sollen sah
vorher besser aus besser
natürlich und gesund sie sieht halt ganz
natürlich aus so
also ich finde sie hätte auch andere
Wege finden können wie sie besser
aussieht statt so viele Operation
[Musik]